el presidente chileno gabriel boric
manifestó en una entrevista al canal
chileno chilevisión que de resultar
ganador la opción del rechazo en el
próximo plebiscito constitucional
previsto para el 4 de septiembre no se
iniciaría un nuevo plebiscito sobre la
forma en que reiniciar este proceso
constitucional es decir simplemente se
avanzaría en optar por unos nuevos
convencionales constituyentes que
eligieran una nueva propuesta o que
conformarán una nueva propuesta
constitucional esto cuando en el clima
de chile vuelve a reinar la
incertidumbre absoluta sobre los
resultados del próximo plebiscito en el
que los chilenos decidirán si optan por
la propuesta de la convención
constitucional o si mantienen el texto
constitucional actual que data de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet de 1980 y
que ha sido muy repudiada a lo largo de
los últimos 30 años en el país si se
ganará el rechazo por tanto se abriría
de nuevo un proceso de elegir de nuevo a
convencionales constitucionales que
elaborarán un nuevo texto constitucional
mientras las encuestas publicadas por
última vez el pasado sábado porque la
ley chilena prohíbe la publicación de
encuestas 15 días antes del plebiscito
señalan como coincidente a ganador a la
opción del rechazo que se impondría en
las distintas encuestas en algunas de
ellas por más de 10 puntos de diferencia
las encuestas no siempre han acertado en
los procesos electorales chilenos es
todavía muy incierto lo que puede pasar
el próximo 4 de septiembre mientras que
las campañas de la propia el rechazo
última en sus últimos cartuchos de
salida